This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听的是《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都无法安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你们是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，听着，去学习。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是Michael Easter。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将是他最后一个目标。他不会得逞的。他会得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Trust Me, Babe》。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年说起，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。我是Sam J。我是Alex English。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理清我们是如何度过那段时光的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the Psychology of Your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Well, hello, thank you for tuning into the psychology of your 20s for this episode.
和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那确实是疯狂的一年。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人来说。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at It》。你好，欢迎回到《Psychology of Your 20s》，在这个播客中，我们讨论20多岁时的一些重大变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。嗯，你好，感谢收听本期《Psychology of Your 20s》。
This week's topic, we're going to be talking about alcohol. and alcohol consumption in our 20s, there is so much that we could talk about when it comes to drinking and the culture around drinking, binge drinking, peer pressure. It would genuinely take, I think, a whole series of episodes to really uncover all the links between alcohol and psychology and our 20s. So I thought for this episode, we'd start pretty simple, but we'd start strong. and we talk about anxiety, so anxiety that you feel after you've been drinking. I think that alcohol is such an important topic to discuss when we're thinking about our
本周的话题，我们要谈谈酒精。以及我们在20多岁时的饮酒问题，关于饮酒以及围绕饮酒的文化、酗酒、同辈压力，有太多可以谈论的了。我想，这真的需要一整个系列的节目才能真正揭开酒精与心理以及我们20多岁生活之间的所有联系。所以我认为在这一集中，我们从简单的开始，但要深入探讨。我们谈谈焦虑，也就是你喝酒后感到的那种焦虑。我认为酒精是一个非常重要的话题，当我们思考我们的
psychology and our well-being and how that interacts with other factors in our life in this decade. Alcohol plays a pretty profound role, I would say, for those of us who choose to drink, especially in Australia where I'm from. I think alcohol is kind of a central feature of a lot of social interactions. We go to the pub. We get drinks on a Friday. We drink after work.
心理和幸福感，以及它如何与我们这个十年生活中其他因素相互作用时。酒精扮演着相当深远的角色，我想说，对于我们这些选择喝酒的人来说，尤其是在我来自的澳大利亚。我认为酒精是许多社交互动中的一个核心特征。我们去酒吧。我们在周五喝酒。我们下班后喝酒。
We drink on birthdays. We drink at the beach. Like a lot of social elements all rest upon drinking and a pretty strong drinking culture especially. And I think that as well, alcohol is something that a lot of us will, you know, drinking in our late teens, but in our 20s when we can kind of access it more easily, when we have money to purchase alcohol, consumption kind of goes up. And like I said, it's a big part of our lives, a big part of our social lives. So it's important to talk about and to talk
我们在生日时喝酒。我们在海滩上喝酒。很多社交元素都建立在饮酒之上，尤其是一种非常强烈的饮酒文化。而且我认为，酒精也是我们许多人会接触的东西，你知道，我们在青少年晚期开始喝酒，但在20多岁时，当我们更容易获得它，当我们有钱购买酒精时，消费量就会上升。就像我说的，这是我们生活的重要组成部分，是我们社交生活的重要组成部分。所以谈论它很重要，而且要以
about in a healthy way and in a nuanced way considering other things that it involves like our mental health. I think drinking in particular is, really takes a big, becomes a big feature of our lives when we go to uni or when we're in our early 20s and you start drinking in college or with friends that you've made in trades or from high school. And there is a really big binge drinking mentality. I especially found that at college, you know, there was no kind of limit. We didn't have a good understanding of how much it would take to get us really drunk. And even if we did, we'd probably still drink past that point. And we've all had, I think, for those of us who choose to drink, have stories about, you know, when we've taken it too far, when we haven't eaten anything and
一种健康和细致入微的方式来谈论它，考虑到它所涉及的其他事情，比如我们的心理健康。我认为饮酒尤其如此，当我们上大学或20岁出头时，它真的成为了我们生活的一个重要特征，你开始在大学里或与你在工作中或高中结识的朋友一起喝酒。而且有一种非常强烈的酗酒心态。我特别在大学里发现这一点，你知道，根本没有所谓的限制。我们对喝多少才会真正喝醉没有很好的理解。即使我们知道，我们可能还是会喝过头。而且我认为，对于我们这些选择喝酒的人来说，都有过这样的故事，你知道，当我们喝得太多，当我们什么都没吃，
then done a couple shots or had a few too many beers with our friends at the pub. And there is a big culture around that. So I think it's something to discuss, especially in our 20s, because it isn't all just fun and gains. There can be consequences both in the long term and on a really serious level, like alcoholism or excessive drinking or doing shit that like really fucks up your life, getting injured, making mistakes. But then there's also the kind of less severe, more short-term impacts on our mental well-being and on our psychology, such as anxiety, which is really important to have a discussion around. As we, we have a question around, as we have. mature, you know, I hopefully begin to learn healthier habits around alcohol. I definitely have
然后喝了几杯烈酒，或者在酒吧和朋友多喝了几杯啤酒。围绕这一点有一种很大的文化。所以我认为这是一个值得讨论的话题，尤其是在我们20多岁的时候，因为它并不全是乐趣和收获。长期来看可能会有后果，在非常严重的层面上，比如酗酒或过度饮酒，或者做一些真正搞砸你生活的事情，受伤，犯错。但也有一些不太严重、更短期的对我们心理健康和心理的影响，比如焦虑，围绕这一点进行讨论非常重要。随着我们，我们有一个关于，随着我们，
a lot of my friends and I have been discussing how we really can't drink the way that we did when we were 20 or 21 and, you know, going out like three nights in a row. Nowadays, that's just completely out of the picture for me. And I think a massive reason is because it doesn't, that excessive drinking doesn't really fit well into the narrative I have around my mental health or my psychological well-being, which has become more important to me than those kind of wild stories or getting home at 4 a.m. So there is a lot to talk about when we're discussing the intersections of psychology and alcohol, but of course I'm going to limit myself to anxiety, something I think we can all relate to if we drink, especially if we've had a big night. We're going to talk about
成熟，你知道，我希望开始学习围绕酒精更健康的习惯。我绝对有，我和我的很多朋友一直在讨论我们真的不能像20岁或21岁那样喝酒了，你知道，连续三个晚上出去玩。如今，这对我来说完全是不可能的。而且我认为一个巨大的原因是，那种过度饮酒并不符合我围绕心理健康或心理幸福感的叙述，这对我来说已经变得比那些疯狂的故事或凌晨4点回家更重要了。所以当我们讨论心理学和酒精的交叉点时，有很多话要说，但当然我会把自己限制在焦虑上，我认为如果我们喝酒，尤其是如果我们经历了一个疯狂的夜晚，我们都能感同身受。我们要谈谈
why our brain reacts to alcohol in that way, if you're someone who experiences anxiety. the consequences and also how to maybe limit it, how to get over that weird, anxious, depressive period the day after you've been drinking or the week after you've been drinking, how to kind of move past that and have a healthier relationship with alcohol and with your body so that you don't have that kind of negative come down. So I hope you all enjoy and we learn something today. Okay, so for those of you who don't know what anxiety is, it's a pretty common term I don't know amongst my kind of friendship group if you haven't heard of it before if maybe you're from a different country where this isn't a term essentially it describes that kind of pretty
为什么我们的大脑会以那种方式对酒精做出反应，如果你是一个经历焦虑的人。后果以及如何可能限制它，如何克服喝酒后的第二天或喝酒后的一周那种奇怪的、焦虑的、抑郁的时期，如何摆脱那种状态，并与酒精和你的身体建立更健康的关系，这样你就不会有那种负面的崩溃。所以我希望你们都喜欢，我们今天能学到一些东西。好的，所以对于那些不知道什么是焦虑的人来说，这是一个相当常见的术语，我不知道在我的朋友圈里，如果你以前没听说过它，如果也许你来自一个不同的国家，这不是一个术语，本质上它描述了那种相当
common anxious feeling of dread or nervousness after a night of drinking it might also be linked to a feeling of embarrassment or doom that you've done something really stupid as you're recovering from a big night or a big day. Generally, it's just describing a feeling or a state of heightened alertness and anxiety and stress or fear that we can directly link to a period or an episode of excessive drinking. Now, if you are someone who experiences anxiety or stress after you've been drinking a lot, you are by no means the only one. Anxiety during a hangover affects around. 20% of people from some estimates and can pretty much vary in severity as many things do, depending on the kind of person you are, depending on other factors that are impacting your
常见的喝酒后那种焦虑的恐惧或紧张感，它也可能与一种尴尬或厄运感有关，即你在从一个疯狂的夜晚或忙碌的一天中恢复时，做了一些非常愚蠢的事情。通常，它只是描述一种高度警觉和焦虑、压力或恐惧的状态，我们可以直接将其与一段或一次过度饮酒的经历联系起来。现在，如果你是一个在喝了很多酒后经历焦虑或压力的人，你绝不是唯一一个。宿醉期间的焦虑影响着大约20%的人，根据一些估计，而且严重程度可能会有很大差异，就像许多事情一样，取决于你是哪种人，取决于当时你喝酒时影响你
psychological state at the time that you were drinking, but also the morning after when you might be experiencing some of those hangover side effects. So as the body recovers from a night of drinking, from binge drinking, a hangover can create a a state of physiological stress. So that often happens when the body is under pressure, like after an illness or injury, and alcohol can create the same kind of impact on us. So this isn't so much about anxiety. This is some of the physical effects that we might experience after a hangover or after a big night of drinking, you know, the headaches, the sweating, nausea, all of those things. And anxiety kind of works the same way. Not only does it cause changes
心理状态的其他因素，也取决于第二天早上你可能会经历的一些宿醉副作用。因此，当身体从一夜的饮酒、酗酒中恢复时，宿醉会产生一种生理压力状态。这通常发生在身体承受压力时，比如生病或受伤后，酒精也会对我们产生同样的影响。所以这与其说是关于焦虑。这是我们在宿醉或疯狂饮酒后可能会经历的一些身体影响，你知道，头痛、出汗、恶心，所有这些事情。而焦虑的作用方式也差不多。它不仅会导致
to our immune system, it also increases our cortisol levels, that's known as the stress hormone, our blood pressure, our heart rate, and then on a deeper level, on a more psychological, neurological level, it also changes the neurochemicals and neurotransmitters being released in our brain. And what does that feel like? What does that anxiety feel like? Well, I kind of alluded to this, But as I've gotten older, obviously I'm not that old and still in my 20s, but as I have had more things kind of come onto my plate, as I've matured, as I've grown, as I've had more responsibilities, as my brain is kind of developed and formed, as it often does in our early and mid-20s, what I found is when I drink, if I've had a really big night, I haven't been watching what I've been drinking. I had this happen recently at a work function. the champagne was flowing and the next morning and especially the next day I was just feeling so panicky and nervous and stressed and flighty even though I didn't feel like I'd done anything embarrassing
我们的免疫系统发生变化，它还会增加我们的皮质醇水平，也就是所谓的压力荷尔蒙，我们的血压、心率，然后在更深层次上，在更心理、神经学的层面上，它还会改变我们大脑中释放的神经化学物质和神经递质。那感觉如何？那种焦虑感觉如何？嗯，我刚才提到了这一点，但随着我年龄的增长，显然我没那么老，还在20多岁，但随着我手头的事情越来越多，随着我成熟，随着我成长，随着我有了更多的责任，随着我的大脑像我们在20岁出头和中期经常发生的那样发育和形成，我发现当我喝酒时，如果我经历了一个非常疯狂的夜晚，我没有注意我在喝什么。我最近在一次工作聚会上发生了这种情况，香槟流淌，第二天早上，尤其是第二天，我感到非常恐慌、紧张、压力大和浮躁，即使我觉得我没有做任何尴尬的事情，
I hadn't really done anything or nothing had happened that had given me a reason to feel anxious I could recognize that the amount of alcohol I drank the night before had actually caused changes in my body that were making me feel really really shit and I have had so many friends who have told me similar things recently after big nights out. Not only do they have those normal hangover symptoms that we all kind of expect, the sweating, the nausea, the headache, feeling vile, but they were also really anxious for no reason. Or for one reason, which was that the amount of alcohol they're drunk had impacted their brain and created a sense of arousal and a sense of anxiety. This can feel really terrible.
我真的没做什么，或者什么都没发生，让我有理由感到焦虑，我能意识到我前一天晚上喝的酒精量实际上导致了我的身体发生了变化，让我感觉非常非常糟糕，而且我有很多朋友最近在疯狂的夜晚后告诉过我类似的事情。他们不仅有我们都预料到的那些正常的宿醉症状，出汗、恶心、头痛、感觉恶心，而且他们还无缘无故地非常焦虑。或者有一个原因，那就是他们喝的酒精量影响了他们的大脑，产生了一种唤醒感和一种焦虑感。这感觉真的很糟糕。
I think a big reaction that I normally have is like I'm never drinking again. I'm never drinking to that level again. We all know that's not the case. If you are someone who drinks and drinks socially, it's very easy for things to get out of hand, especially if someone's buying drinks, if it's a function. So it is important to understand if you do continue drinking after a bad anxiety episode. It's important to understand why this state of psychological arousal occurs and how we can kind of bounce back from a big night without that terribly anxious feeling causing us to dread the future or dread our current state. So yeah, you're probably, you know, pretty familiar with the usual physical symptoms of a hangover, but like I said, it can have psychological symptoms as
我认为我通常的一个大反应是，我再也不喝酒了。我再也不会喝到那种程度了。我们都知道事实并非如此。如果你是一个喝酒并且社交饮酒的人，事情很容易失控，特别是如果有人请客，如果这是一个聚会。所以，如果你在一次严重的焦虑发作后继续喝酒，了解这一点很重要。了解这种心理唤醒状态为什么会发生，以及我们如何才能从一个疯狂的夜晚中恢复过来，而不会让那种可怕的焦虑感导致我们对未来或我们当前的状态感到恐惧，这一点很重要。所以是的，你可能，你知道，对宿醉的常见身体症状非常熟悉，但就像我说的，它也可能有心理症状。
well. So anxiety is that link between our psychological state and having a hangover. This can mean that when you are experiencing anxiety during a hangover, where you're worried about something you did under the influence, or maybe you're regretting things, trying to remember the evening, or maybe just feeling a little bit off, we can attribute this not so much to what we would see as the physical reactions to alcohol, but the psychological, neurological reactions to alcohol. And if you already suffer from anxiety or depression, even social anxiety, experiencing a hangover can make those symptoms of anxiety a lot worse. Even though alcohol can lessen feelings of anxiety whilst drinking, which we're going to talk about a little bit later, there is that rebound
所以焦虑是我们心理状态和宿醉之间的联系。这意味着当你经历宿醉期间的焦虑时，你担心你在酒精影响下做的事情，或者也许你后悔了，试图回忆那个晚上，或者也许只是感觉有点不对劲，我们可以将其归因于酒精的心理、神经反应，而不是我们所看到的酒精的身体反应。而且如果你已经患有焦虑症或抑郁症，甚至是社交焦虑症，经历宿醉会使那些焦虑症状变得更糟。尽管酒精在饮酒时可以减轻焦虑感，我们稍后会谈到这一点，但存在那种反弹
effect that may make you feel far worse and feeling beyond your normal symptoms of stress and anxiety the following morning. And unfortunately, experiencing those uncomfortable emotions can make us feel like maybe we're not drinking enough alcohol to mask those feelings, making you drink more and more, especially if you know you've had a big day out in the town and you're kind of playing catch up and you've been drinking for a while and those feelings of anxiety are coming up as you're still kind of in a social setting. It can cause us to drink more. And many people do use alcohol as kind of a social lubricant as a bit of liquid courage as my friends and I always say before one of us goes on a date. you know, a few shots of fireball kind of loosens you up. And if you live with anxiety,
效应，可能会让你感觉比第二天早上正常的压力和焦虑症状要糟糕得多。不幸的是，经历那些不舒服的情绪可能会让我们觉得也许我们喝的酒精不足以掩盖那些感觉，让你喝得越来越多，特别是如果你知道你已经在城里度过了疯狂的一天，你有点在赶进度，而且你已经喝了一段时间，当你还在社交场合时，那些焦虑感就会出现。这会导致我们喝得更多。许多人确实把酒精当作一种社交润滑剂，当作一点点液体勇气，就像我和我的朋友在其中一个人去约会前总是说的那样。你知道，几杯火球威士忌让你放松。如果你患有焦虑症，
particularly social anxiety, you will find that having a drink or two before a big social event or when you arrive will help you relax and cope with anxious feelings. And this is why. This is why we have that initial reaction of feeling more calm, more at ease, perhaps more social, and why it actually is completely and inextricably linked to the anxiety you'll feel the next day. So alcohol, it is what we would class as a downer drug. So we have uppers, which is things like MDMA or caffeine and downers. So basically downers reduce arousal and activity within our central nervous system by targeting different receptors and neurotransmitters in our brain.
特别是社交焦虑症，你会发现，在大型社交活动前或到达时喝一两杯酒会帮助你放松并应对焦虑感。这就是原因。这就是为什么我们会有那种感觉更冷静、更自在、也许更善于社交的初步反应，以及为什么它实际上与你第二天感到的焦虑完全且不可分割地联系在一起。所以酒精，它是我们归类为抑制剂的药物。所以我们有兴奋剂，比如MDMA或咖啡因，还有抑制剂。所以基本上抑制剂通过靶向我们大脑中不同的受体和神经递质来减少我们中枢神经系统内的唤醒和活动。
So alcohol in particular targets the GABA receptor. So in our brain we have neurotransmitters, which are those tiny little hormonal or chemical messages that get sent around, things like dopamine and serotonin, which we've talked about before. And then you have the parts of the neuron. And one of those is a receptor. And the receptor is kind of like the front door. It's the thing that allows the neurotransmitters to come in. But alcohol targets that receptor, the GABA receptors, which send signals through the brain and the central nervous system to inhibit the activity of a nerve cell. So basically alcohol kind of makes that receptor shut the door more frequently on other neurotransmitters coming in. So put simply, when you first start drinking, it calms the brain and it reduces excitement by making fewer neurons fire. So because alcohol targets or stimulates GABA receptors, this is why you, if you have anxiety or, you know, you're just a general person, why you might start to feel relaxed and cheerful when you're a few classes in, when you've had a, you know, I've had a few drinks. And it kind of causes you to relax.
所以酒精特别靶向GABA受体。所以我们的大脑中有神经递质，它们是那些在周围发送的微小的荷尔蒙或化学信息，比如多巴胺和血清素，我们之前谈到过。然后你有神经元的各个部分。其中之一是受体。受体有点像前门。它是允许神经递质进入的东西。但酒精靶向那个受体，GABA受体，它通过大脑和中枢神经系统发送信号来抑制神经细胞的活动。所以基本上酒精有点让那个受体更频繁地对进入的其他神经递质关上门。所以简单地说，当你刚开始喝酒时，它通过减少神经元放电来冷静大脑并减少兴奋。所以因为酒精靶向或刺激GABA受体，这就是为什么你，如果你有焦虑，或者，你知道，你只是一个普通人，为什么当你喝了几杯，当你喝了几杯酒时，你可能会开始感到放松和愉快。而且它让你放松。
So when you've just started drinking, that kind of lulls you into that blissful, gabber induced state of chill. It's kind of like your peak point. But then as you keep drinking more when you get to your third or fourth drink, another brain kind of slackening effect kicks in. Alcohol causes your brain to start blocking a neurotransmitter called glutamate. So glutamate is an excitory neurotransmitter. So it causes activity in your brain to occur more frequently and at a faster rate. So more glutamate means more anxiety. Less glutamate means less anxiety.
所以当你刚开始喝酒时，那种感觉把你带入那种幸福的、GABA诱导的放松状态。这有点像你的峰值点。但当你继续喝更多，当你喝到第三或第四杯时，另一种大脑松弛效应就会启动。酒精导致你的大脑开始阻断一种叫做谷氨酸的神经递质。所以谷氨酸是一种兴奋性神经递质。所以它导致大脑中的活动更频繁、更快速地发生。所以更多的谷氨酸意味着更多的焦虑。更少的谷氨酸意味着更少的焦虑。
So this is why when you get drunk, we're less anxious than when we're just a tiny bit drunk. It's why our social inhibition goes down. It's why we can kind of talk more easily because alcohol has blocked glutamate the neurotransmitter that would normally make you feel kind of anxious or a little bit like suspicious. of your words. Not only does alcohol reduce the chatter in your brain by stimulating gabber, but it further reduces your anxiety by blocking gluten-mate. So that's why you feel really good. You feel like you can have all those weird drunk chats with, you know, people outside the club or at the pub or in the bathroom, why you always have like really deep and meaningful conversations
所以这就是为什么当你喝醉时，我们比只喝了一点点酒时更不焦虑。这就是为什么我们的社交抑制降低了。这就是为什么我们可以更容易地交谈，因为酒精阻断了谷氨酸，这种神经递质通常会让你感到有点焦虑或有点像怀疑你的话。酒精不仅通过刺激GABA减少了你大脑中的杂音，它还通过阻断谷氨酸进一步减少了你的焦虑。所以这就是为什么你感觉非常好。你觉得你可以和，你知道，俱乐部外面或酒吧里或洗手间里的人进行所有那些奇怪的醉酒聊天，为什么你总是和人进行非常深刻和有意义的对话，
with people. Because normally glutamate would be telling your brain to kind of, you know, reel it in a little bit to stay alert, but when that's not around as much, we're more chilled out. So the body registers this imbalance in brain chemicals, and it kind of attempts to put things right. So it's kind of like when you eat a lot of sugar and your body starts producing a lot of insulin to process that sugar and to get your blood sugar levels back to normal. But as soon as you've digested all of those marshmallows or chubber chubs or whatever you've eaten, all that insulin causes your blood sugar to crash. And then your body has to try and get it back up to a normal level.
因为通常谷氨酸会告诉你的大脑，你知道，稍微收敛一点，保持警觉，但当它不在身边时，我们更放松了。所以身体会记录这种大脑化学物质的不平衡，它会试图纠正它。所以这有点像当你吃了很多糖，你的身体开始产生大量的胰岛素来处理那些糖，并使你的血糖水平恢复正常。但一旦你消化了所有那些棉花糖或棒棒糖或无论你吃了什么，所有那些胰岛素就会导致你的血糖崩溃。然后你的身体必须尝试把它恢复到一个正常的水平。
So when you're really drunk, your body realizes that something isn't right. A foreign substance, alcohol has come into your body and it's kind of messing with your neurotransmitters and your gaba receptors and your glutamate levels. So when you stop drinking, you will end up with a naturally low gaba function and a spike in glutamate because you're, body and your mind is trying to compensate for the fact that the alcohol has kind of numbed you a little bit. This is why we feel anxiety or have withdrawal from alcohol. This is why we get
所以当你喝得很醉时，你的身体意识到有些不对劲。一种外来物质，酒精进入了你的身体，它有点在干扰你的神经递质和你的GABA受体以及你的谷氨酸水平。所以当你停止喝酒时，你最终会得到一个自然低的GABA功能和谷氨酸的激增，因为你的身体和你的思想正在试图补偿酒精有点麻痹你的事实。这就是为什么我们感到焦虑或有酒精戒断反应。这就是为什么我们得到
anxiety. So essentially what's going to happen is that after you've been drinking, your brain, once there's less alcohol in your system, is going to pick up that there isn't enough glutamate or the right status quo amount of glutamate to let us function. So it's going to shoot production and release of those neutral transmitters back up. And we know that glutamate is associated with anxiety. So to compensate for that deficit in glutamate from the night before, it's going to produce a lot. And so you're going to start feeling quite tense and anxious. And it can take the brain a day or two to kind of return to its normal state.
焦虑。所以本质上会发生的是，在你喝酒后，一旦你系统中的酒精减少，你的大脑就会发现没有足够的谷氨酸或适量的谷氨酸来让我们正常运作。所以它会把那些神经递质的产生和释放重新调高。而且我们知道谷氨酸与焦虑有关。为了补偿前一天晚上谷氨酸的不足，它会产生很多。所以你会开始感到相当紧张和焦虑。而且大脑可能需要一两天才能恢复到正常状态。
And if you drank for an awfully long time, it can also sometimes take a week. for your brain to readapt. And the consequences of that and why it relates to anxiety is that during that time that your brain is trying to restore normal functioning, you're going to feel really anxious and you're going to feel really tense. It's kind of the seesaw of emotion and psychological states where you're at one end right down the bottom and now you're way up the other side and your brain is trying to find that balance so that you can get back to a normal state of functioning, a normal state of arousal,
而且如果你喝了很长时间，有时也可能需要一周时间让你的大脑重新适应。其后果以及它为什么与焦虑有关是，在那段时间里，当你的大脑试图恢复正常功能时，你会感到非常焦虑，你会感到非常紧张。这有点像情绪和心理状态的跷跷板，你在底部的一端，现在你在另一边，你的大脑正在试图找到那种平衡，这样你就可以回到正常的运作状态，正常的唤醒状态，
and your brain can recover from a big night. So imbalances in GABA and glutamate are not the only problem. There are some deeper interactions that create anxiety and that feeling of anxiousness and stress after you've had a big night of drinking or out of it. Okay, so we've talked about Gabba and we've talked about glutamate, but alcohol can also cause a rise in nor a adrenaline. And this is known as our fight or flight hormone. So noradrenaline suppresses stress when it's first released and increases in withdrawal. So severe anxiety is often associated with a surge in noradrenaline in the brain. Let me kind of explain. So sorry, so yeah, it's normally associated with a surge of noradrenaline. So when you can, you can, you know,
你的大脑可以从一个疯狂的夜晚中恢复过来。所以GABA和谷氨酸的不平衡并不是唯一的问题。还有一些更深层次的相互作用，在你经历了一个疯狂的饮酒之夜或之后，会产生焦虑和那种焦虑感和压力感。好的，所以我们谈到了GABA，我们谈到了谷氨酸，但酒精也会导致去甲肾上腺素的升高。这就是所谓的我们的战斗或逃跑荷尔蒙。所以去甲肾上腺素在最初释放时抑制压力，并在戒断时增加。所以严重的焦虑通常与大脑中去甲肾上腺素的激增有关。让我解释一下。所以抱歉，所以是的，它通常与去甲肾上腺素的激增有关。所以当你，你可以，你知道，
consume alcohol. Basically, our brain suppresses this hormone so you feel less aroused, less stressed. But then once you stop drinking, it tries to return to normal levels. And that's another key cause of anxiety. And another reason why we might feel it and might be anxious the next day is because you might find that you're not able to remember some of the things that you've done whilst you're inebriated. And that's because we need things like noradrenaline and glutamate and all of those kind of systems to remember things and consolidate memories. And we also need noradrenaline to tell us and tell our brain when something's really important
饮酒。基本上，我们的大脑抑制这种荷尔蒙，所以你感到更少的唤醒，更少的压力。但一旦你停止喝酒，它就会试图恢复到正常水平。这是焦虑的另一个关键原因。我们第二天可能会感到焦虑的另一个原因是，你可能会发现你无法记住你在醉酒时所做的一些事情。这是因为我们需要去甲肾上腺素和谷氨酸以及所有那些系统来记住事情并巩固记忆。而且我们还需要去甲肾上腺素来告诉我们并告诉我们的大脑什么时候某件事非常重要，
and we should probably remember it. So if we don't have normal levels of that, our brain isn't able to kind of lay down memories in the same way. So that it might also just be. another underlying reason why you're pretty anxious the next day because you're thinking back on your night, there's things that you can't remember. You're like, did I say something embarrassing? Did I do something embarrassing? Or you can kind of only remember flashes of it and it's enough to make you feel stressed. That's because of an imbalance in your brain where your brain isn't
我们可能应该记住它。所以如果我们没有正常的水平，我们的大脑就无法以同样的方式存储记忆。所以这可能也只是你第二天非常焦虑的另一个潜在原因，因为你在回想你的夜晚，有些事情你记不住。你在想，我说了什么尴尬的话吗？我做了什么尴尬的事情吗？或者你只能记得它的片段，这足以让你感到压力。这是因为你大脑中的不平衡，你的大脑无法
able to consolidate memories as well. And if that's ringing any bells, it may be because anxiety associated with that and in general doesn't affect us all. as revealed by this really interesting study that was published in a journal called personality and individual differences. So this was conducted in 2019 and it looked at, I think, around 100 people and what they wanted to measure is how does alcohol impact us differently based on our varying levels of social openness or shyness? So researchers asked 50 of the participants to drink as they usually would in a social situation and the other half of the participants to stay sober. And then they measured the levels of anxiety before, during and after the period where people
很好地巩固记忆。如果这听起来很耳熟，那可能是因为与之相关的焦虑，以及在一般情况下，它并不影响我们所有人。正如发表在《人格与个体差异》杂志上的一项非常有趣的研究所揭示的那样。这是在2019年进行的，它观察了大约100人，他们想要测量的是酒精如何根据我们不同程度的社交开放性或害羞程度对我们产生不同的影响？所以研究人员要求50名参与者在社交场合像往常一样喝酒，另一半参与者保持清醒。然后他们测量了人们在
were either drinking or they were sober. And according to the authors, the people who were more shy had much higher of levels of anxiety the following day than people who weren't shy. And they also found a correlation between having bad anxiety and the chances of of having an alcohol use disorder or using alcohol to kind of numb some of those feelings of social anxiety when you're going into a situation. So the interactions that alcohol has with our brain isn't just important for anxiety and feeling nervous the next day, but it might also have a link with problematic drinking if you are someone who's anxious normally.
喝酒或清醒期间之前、期间和之后的焦虑水平。根据作者的说法，比较害羞的人第二天比不害羞的人有高得多的焦虑水平。他们还发现严重的焦虑与患酒精使用障碍或使用酒精来麻痹进入某种情况时的社交焦虑感之间存在相关性。所以酒精与我们大脑的相互作用不仅对焦虑和第二天感到紧张很重要，而且如果你是一个通常焦虑的人，它可能还与问题饮酒有关。
And one theory as to why shy people might be more at risk of anxiety and even sometimes alcohol problems is the possibility of that seesaw effect on gabber levels and it being more pronounced in them. So your baseline gabber levels when you're an anxious person might be lower to start with. And it could also be a psychological effect. People who are more highly anxious are more prone to rumination going over thoughts about the night before. So that's another potential mechanism. Also if your levels of those important hormones, gluten-Aid and noradrenaline, are pretty, high or low to start with, the compensation that your brain has to make the days after drinking is going to be more pronounced. And we know that as noradrenaline and glutamate levels
害羞的人可能更容易受到焦虑甚至有时酒精问题影响的一个理论是，GABA水平上的那种跷跷板效应在他们身上可能更明显。所以当你是一个焦虑的人时，你的基线GABA水平可能一开始就较低。这也可能是一种心理效应。更高度焦虑的人更容易反刍，反复思考前一天晚上的想法。所以这是另一个潜在的机制。此外，如果你的那些重要荷尔蒙，谷氨酸和去甲肾上腺素的水平，一开始就相当高或低，你的大脑在喝酒后的几天里必须做出的补偿就会更明显。而且我们知道，随着去甲肾上腺素和谷氨酸水平
are restored, anxiety and stress comes with it. So if you're someone who's shy and you had lower levels of that to begin with or higher levels in some cases, it kind of swings back around and can really knock you on your butt. So the study also does have a lot of, you know, implications. After all, I think a lot of us as drinkers, or if you do drink at some point or another, do lean on alcohol to kind of make us more easygoing, make friends easier, and as a social lubricant to some degree in a lot of social settings. But if you're someone who is repeatedly using alcohol for those reasons and drinking to excess, it might be because there is kind of an imbalance in your brain, or you are experiencing more anxiety around social interactions in general,
恢复，焦虑和压力也随之而来。所以如果你是一个害羞的人，你一开始的水平就较低，或者在某些情况下较高，它会反弹回来，真的会让你措手不及。所以这项研究确实有很多，你知道，启示。毕竟，我认为我们许多作为饮酒者，或者如果你在某个时候喝酒，确实会依赖酒精来让我们更随和，更容易交朋友，并在许多社交场合在某种程度上作为社交润滑剂。但如果你是一个反复因为这些原因使用酒精并过度饮酒的人，那可能是因为你的大脑中存在某种不平衡，或者你在一般社交互动中经历了更多的焦虑，
so your brain is compensating and you're experiencing worse hangovers, more anxiety the next day. This type of anxiety, it might not happen every time you drink. And although I have kind of said that people who are naturally shy or less socially kind of interested might experience anxiety more, it isn't just confined to that group of people. Of course, there are external and extraneous things and context in our lives. that we need to think of and consider when we're thinking about this reaction to alcohol. If you're going through a difficult time in your life, yes, it might be a reaction to lean on alcohol as a crutch because it is a socially acceptable drug, because it does make you feel
所以你的大脑在补偿，你正在经历更严重的宿醉，第二天更多的焦虑。这种类型的焦虑，它可能不会在你每次喝酒时都发生。虽然我已经说过，天生害羞或社交兴趣较少的人可能会更多地经历焦虑，但这并不局限于那群人。当然，我们生活中还有外部和无关的事情和背景。当我们思考这种对酒精的反应时，我们需要考虑。如果你正在经历生活中困难的时期，是的，这可能是一种依赖酒精作为拐杖的反应，因为它是一种社会可接受的药物，因为它确实让你感觉
better. And if you're feeling anxious and stressed in the short term, you're going to feel amazing. But if you have all those things, if you've got something really stressful going on, you'll probably be responding differently to alcohol than if you know you just come back from holiday or you're feeling really great or you're feeling really confident. Somebody who isn't experiencing any issues with mood might also notice anxiety, but it's probably going to be more physiologically based and more to do what happened the night before rather than some kind of imbalance which is causing stress for no reason. There's also the case of certain medications. So if you're already taking anxiety levels with interacting upon noradrenaline and serotonin and glutamate and your gabber receptors or even anti-inflammatory
更好。如果你在短期内感到焦虑和压力，你会感觉很棒。但如果你有所有这些事情，如果你有真正压力大的事情发生，你对酒精的反应可能与你知道你刚从假期回来，或者你感觉非常好，或者你感觉非常自信时不同。一个没有经历任何情绪问题的人也可能会注意到焦虑，但这可能更多是基于生理的，更多是与前一天晚上发生的事情有关，而不是某种导致无缘无故压力的不平衡。还有某些药物的情况。所以如果你已经在服用与去甲肾上腺素、血清素和谷氨酸以及你的GABA受体相互作用的焦虑药物，或者甚至是抗炎
medications like ibuprofen. I know before I went out, people are always like, don't take any panadol or aspirin or anything like that because it will have an effect with alcohol. These will interact and your medications may be less effective, which is why you might feel more anxious, restless or agitated. If you're taking a medication for anxiety, people who've made that medication, they're considering you being completely sober. Of course they've done studies to see the interactions between that medication and alcohol, but they're just trying to make it so that you can function on the daily when you're not drinking. So excessive binge drinking is something that needs to be taken into account
药物，比如布洛芬。我知道在我出去之前，人们总是说，不要服用任何必理通或阿司匹林或类似的东西，因为它会与酒精产生影响。这些会相互作用，你的药物可能效果较差，这就是为什么你可能会感到更焦虑、烦躁或激动。如果你正在服用治疗焦虑的药物，制造那种药物的人，他们考虑的是你完全清醒的情况。当然，他们已经做了研究来看看那种药物和酒精之间的相互作用，但他们只是试图让你在不喝酒时能正常生活。所以过度酗酒是需要考虑的事情，
if you are choosing to take medications for an anxiety disorder or any other thing that you might already have going on. And some medications also carry a risk of other side effects like memory impairment, which is another big reason why the next day you might be feeling a little bit of regret if you can't really figure out what actually happened. And then of course there's the more serious things like organ damage and ulcers, especially if you're taking kidney or liver medication as well. So if you do feel anxious the morning after,
如果你选择服用治疗焦虑症的药物或你可能已经有的任何其他事情。而且一些药物还带有其他副作用的风险，比如记忆障碍，这是第二天你可能会感到一点后悔的另一个重要原因，如果你真的弄不清楚到底发生了什么。然后当然还有更严重的事情，比如器官损伤和溃疡，特别是如果你也在服用肾脏或肝脏药物的话。所以如果你第二天早上确实感到焦虑，
it's important to recognize and understand why that might be the case before you kind of panic. You need to be really kind to yourself. You should go for a walk. Breathe really deeply. Talk to a friend whose judgment you can trust. If you're nervous about something you've done the night before, if that's why you're experiencing anxiety, I love doing this with my friends,
在恐慌之前，认识并理解为什么会这样很重要。你需要对自己非常好。你应该去散步。深呼吸。和一位你信任其判断的朋友交谈。如果你对前一天晚上做的事情感到紧张，如果这就是你经历焦虑的原因，我喜欢和我的朋友们这样做，
having a bit of a debrief. And it's probably the fact that there really isn't anything to worry about. But we also know that sometimes when we do drink too much, you can become a bit disinhibited. and our behaviour might be, or we might do things that we otherwise wouldn't do. And that's where understanding the mind-body connection really is quite important if you're experiencing a lot of psychological symptoms associated with a big night of drinking. Feeling physically well, it won't completely resolve anxiety,
进行一点总结。事实可能确实没什么可担心的。但我们也知道，有时当我们喝得太多时，你可能会变得有点失去抑制。而且我们的行为可能是，或者我们可能会做一些我们否则不会做的事情。这就是为什么如果你在经历与疯狂饮酒之夜相关的许多心理症状时，理解身心联系确实非常重要。感觉身体健康，它不会完全解决焦虑，
but it can make you better equipped to tackle some of those racing thoughts and those worries and those regrets and those feelings. The first one is to rehydrate, to drink. Our body is very finely tuned and requires a lot of upkeep and will tell you when things are not right. One of those big things that, you know, I think we think about, but not that often is levels of water in the body. That's really important for getting alcohol out of your bloodstream, for detoxing your body, but also diluting the impacts of alcohol in the blood and the impact that will have on your brain. So drinking a lot of water the day after, we swear by drinking a lot of water the night before,
但它可以让你更有能力应对那些奔涌的想法和那些担忧、那些遗憾和那些感觉。第一个是补水，去喝水。我们的身体调节得非常好，需要大量的维护，并且会在事情不对劲时告诉你。其中一件大事，你知道，我认为我们考虑过，但不是那么经常，是身体中的水分水平。这对将酒精从你的血液中排出，对排毒你的身体，以及稀释酒精在血液中的影响以及它对你大脑的影响非常重要。所以第二天喝大量的水，我们发誓前一天晚上喝大量的水，
it's going to make you feel better. I also have some friends who swear by exercising the next day. Don't get it, never been a fan, like pretty much bottom of the list of things that I want to do, but kind of sweating it out and releasing some of that anxiety through exercise and through a healthy outlet is really amazing. Of course, you can always sleep it off, wait until it's all passed. That's a good idea. But, you know, if you've got a day, if you've been drinking on a Sunday, you've got things to do the next day, sometimes it's not possible to stay in bed. So another solution that I sometimes do is just meditate. Deep, slow breathing can help relax
会让你感觉更好。我也有一些朋友发誓第二天锻炼。我不明白，从来不是粉丝，几乎是我最不想做的事情清单的底部，但通过锻炼和通过健康的出口出汗并释放一些焦虑是非常棒的。当然，你总是可以睡一觉，等到一切过去。这是个好主意。但是，你知道，如果你有一天，如果你在周日喝酒，第二天有事情要做，有时不可能一直躺在床上。所以有时我做的另一个解决方案只是冥想。深、慢的呼吸可以帮助放松
some of those physiological symptoms, which will also connect with your brain and relieve some of that anxiety as well. And meditation is so easy to do if you're someone who really suffers from a heightened nervous system and heightened levels of arousal and rumination the next day. You can do it on your bed. You can do it lying down. You can do it on the train. But it really does help to just kind of close your eyes and focus on your thoughts, how you feel physically and emotionally. And don't try and judge those thoughts or unpack them. Simply just notice them as they come up into your awareness and move along. There's so many good apps for this. So, so many. Do a Google. The Dare app. Amazing. Any meditation podcast on Spotify. Excellent. Anything to help relieve the stress in your brain in a
一些那些生理症状，这也会与你的大脑连接并缓解一些焦虑。而且如果你是一个真正遭受神经系统高度紧张和第二天高度唤醒和反刍的人，冥想非常容易做。你可以在床上做。你可以躺着做。你可以在火车上做。但它确实有助于只是闭上眼睛，专注于你的想法，你身体和情感上的感觉。不要试图评判那些想法或拆解它们。只需在它们进入你的意识时注意到它们，然后继续。有很多好的应用程序可以做这个。非常多。谷歌一下。Dare应用程序。太棒了。Spotify上的任何冥想播客。优秀。任何有助于缓解你大脑压力的事情，以一种
healthy way. Sometimes we might notice that having more alcohol if you're having a bit of a bender might make you feel good on the moment. But often in the long run, it's really not going to make you feel that great because as we've talked about, this whole phenomenon of feeling anxious the day after drinking or after binge drinking is because of the neurotransmitters in your brain being at an imbalance because your body has undergone physical stress, much like an illness, and it's trying to do its job and make you feel better. So it's not worried about whether you're going to, like your brain, that you can't control your conscious experience cannot control what your brain is doing, you know, beyond your
健康的方式。有时我们可能会注意到，如果你喝得有点多，多喝点酒可能会让你当下感觉不错。但从长远来看，这通常不会让你感觉太好，正如我们所讨论的，这种在饮酒或酗酒后第二天感到焦虑的现象，是因为你大脑中的神经递质失衡，因为你的身体经历了类似于疾病的生理压力，它正试图完成它的工作，让你感觉好起来。所以它并不关心你是否会，就像你的大脑一样，你无法控制你的意识体验，无法控制你的大脑在做什么，你知道，超出了你的
control. So if you're like, oh, you know, it'd be really great if we just released glutamate at a slower level so I don't feel anxious or if we, you know, just held off on getting my neurodrenaline levels back to their normal level for a few days because I got a big work conference or something like that. Like your body doesn't care. It just wants you to be back at that equilibrium as fast as possible. So it's about counteracting that impact. That impact. And and taking care of yourself in other ways by eating a good meal, rehydrating, exercising, sweating it out, or even meditating to kind will release some of that tension.
控制范围。所以如果你想，哦，你知道，如果我们能以更慢的速度释放谷氨酸，我就不会感到焦虑，或者如果我们，你知道，推迟几天让我的去甲肾上腺素水平恢复到正常水平，因为我有一个重要的工作会议之类的，那该多好。你的身体根本不在乎。它只是想让你尽快恢复到平衡状态。所以关键在于抵消这种影响。那种影响。并通过吃顿好饭、补充水分、锻炼、出汗，甚至冥想来照顾好自己，以释放一些紧张情绪。
Like I said, if you're someone who has experiences of anxiety, I definitely do at the moment. You know, after drinking, I'm always like, oh my God, I just feel so terrible. I need to talk to my friends about it. Have I done something silly? Often I haven't. It's just because there is a nervous arousal in my body that's telling me to look out for things that could be a threat.
就像我说的，如果你是一个有焦虑经历的人，我目前肯定有。你知道，喝酒后，我总是想，天哪，我感觉太糟糕了。我需要和朋友谈谈。我做了什么傻事吗？通常我没有。这只是因为我体内有一种神经唤醒，在提醒我注意可能存在的威胁。
And I'd say just take it easy on yourself. Maybe try and stop after the third drink. Like I said, two to three drinks is that sweet spot. But I also understand there's a lot of other things that come into our alcohol intake that isn't just self-control. You know, there's peer pressure, people buy you drinks, sometimes you're not noticing what you're drinking. Sometimes you feel like you need to keep up.
我想说的是，对自己放轻松点。也许试着在喝第三杯后停下来。就像我说的，两到三杯是最佳状态。但我也明白，影响我们饮酒量的还有很多其他因素，不仅仅是自控力。你知道，有同伴压力，别人请你喝酒，有时你没注意到自己在喝什么。有时你觉得需要跟上节奏。
up with others or sometimes you just want to have a really good night. You want to really let loose. But being aware of what that does to your psychological well-being and your psychological state in the long term and the morning after is really, really important. Well, thank you so much for listening into this episode. Like I said, there are so many interactions between alcohol and psychology and our 20s. I could talk about it for ages. So if you're interested in hearing some more episodes on the role of alcohol in this important decade in our lives and how that impacts with our mental well-being, reach out on Instagram, tell me what you want to hear.
跟上别人，或者有时你只是想度过一个非常美好的夜晚。你想真正放松一下。但意识到这在长期和第二天早上对你的心理健康和心理状态的影响是非常非常重要的。好吧，非常感谢收听这一集。就像我说的，酒精和心理学以及我们二十多岁的生活之间有很多互动。我可以谈很久。所以如果你有兴趣听更多关于酒精在这个人生重要十年中的作用以及它如何影响我们的心理健康的剧集，请在Instagram上联系我，告诉我你想听什么。
I think peer pressure around drinking is another thing I really want to talk about. And also binge drinking alcohol as kind of an addictive substance is something that I think I could tackle a little bit later on. But it's just so important to be a way. wherever if you choose to drink like I'm sure a lot of us do. I definitely do. But knowing that even though it's a socially acceptable drug, it does still impact us, as I'm sure we've all figured out by now, is really, really crucial. So I hope that you have enjoyed this episode. As always, if you feel cool to do so, if you learned something today, if you think someone else might benefit
我认为饮酒方面的同伴压力是我真正想谈的另一件事。此外，将酗酒作为一种成瘾物质也是我认为稍后可以解决的问题。但无论你是否选择饮酒，就像我相信我们很多人一样，意识到这一点非常重要。我肯定会喝。但要知道，即使它是一种社会可接受的药物，它仍然会影响我们，我相信我们现在都已经明白了，这一点非常非常关键。所以我希望你喜欢这一集。一如既往，如果你觉得可以这样做，如果你今天学到了什么，如果你认为其他人可能会受益
from this episode or another one of the ones that I've made, please leave us a review on either Spotify or Apple Podcasts. Chuck us a follow on Instagram. It really helps the podcast to grow. And it just makes me feel amazing. Lessens my anxiety when I see that people are enjoying this content and the work I put into it. So thank you for those who have already done. So I really appreciate it.
从这一集或我制作的其他剧集中，请在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上给我们留下评论。在Instagram上关注我们。这真的有助于播客的成长。这让我感觉很棒。当我看到人们喜欢这些内容和我投入的工作时，我的焦虑感就减轻了。所以感谢那些已经这样做的人。我真的很感激。
And yes, thank you so much for tuning in. I will be back next week with another episode. I think we're going to have a guest on. So things to look forward to and have a lovely week. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
是的，非常感谢收听。下周我会带着另一集回来。我想我们会请一位嘉宾。所以值得期待，祝你度过愉快的一周。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听的是《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kear Games。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不安全进行的诚实对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover
在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2%。这是在有自动扶梯的情况下选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是Michael Easter。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身和在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现
they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHartRadio app,
她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过，她们采取了行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。听听女朋友们的话。相信我，宝贝，在IHartRadio应用程序上，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
Apple Podcasts，或任何你获取播客的地方。在《Look Back at it》播客上。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是Sam J。我是Alex English。每一集，我们都会选择一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过那一年的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
比如Mark Lamont Hill谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真实。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。